[Music]
it was a normal Tuesday at the
superconductor until a bug in the system
created a small situation now your team
is trapped in 11 separate pocket
dimensions luckily for you there's a
half-finished experimental teleportation
robot that may be able to get you all
home if you can figure out how to work
through the quirks of its design /
interdimensional radio your engineers
explained that the robot can teleport
into the alternate universes you're
trapped in but it'll do so completely at
random the robot has two levers and one
big button when it appears you just
switch the position of one of the levers
from A to B or vice versa and then the
robot will note your dimensional
position and teleport to another of the
eleven dimensions at random if it shows
up again you'll have to pull a lever
before it'll teleport away when anyone
presses the button the robot will bring
everyone who pulled a lever back home
anyone who didn't will be lost in the
multiverse forever the challenge is to
make sure everyone has pulled a lever
before anyone hits the button while you
can talk to each other now over the
interdimensional radio and agree on a
plan the robots teleportation technology
will interfere with all attempts at
communication once it arrives you won't
be able to attach messages to the robot
or scratch notes into its super-strong
alloy body your only way to communicate
information is to change the position of
exactly one lever or hit the button what
plan will make sure everyone gets home
it would be nice if you could set
different combinations of levers to
indicate who's already been visited by
the robot but it has only two levers
that gives four combinations far too few
to communicate about 11 people
especially when you're forced to flip
one to send the robot onward there must
be another way the critical insight is
that not everyone has to know when every
pocket dimension has been visited if one
person accepts responsibility ahead of
time for hitting the button then only
they need to know who the robot has
visited in fact they don't even need to
know exactly who's been visited just how
many people have been you volunteer to
be the person in charge of pressing the
button when the moment is ripe and give
the following directions to everyone
else your plan is simple you'll use the
left lever to count visits and the right
lever will have no meaning so there's no
harm in moving it up or down each of the
others will pull the left lever from
position a to position B exactly once if
the robot appears with the left lever
already pulled down or if an individual
has previously pulled the left lever
down at any point in the past then they
should move the right lever you
meanwhile will be the only one who ever
resets the left lever from position B to
position a this gives you a way to count
how many people have been visited by the
robot everyone needs to pull the left
lever down exactly once and you're the
only one to pull it back up so you know
that the 10th time that the robot visits
you with its left lever in the down
position it must have visited all 10 of
the others and that means you're safe to
press the button and teleport everyone
home it may take a while most likely the
robot will need to teleport around 355
times but better that than leave anyone
behind your teammates phase back into
your home dimension one at a time the
mission proves a great success well
mostly
oops your physics professor just
accidentally stepped through a time
portal and it's your job to make sure he
doesn't end up stranded in history save
the day with this riddle or take a
second to consider whether time travel
is even possible